je préférerais pas avoir à vous déranger
mais je vais me tuer mon idée fait j'ai
seulement cru qu'un adulte devrait être
au courant pour être franc je suis moi
même en train d'écrire ma lettre de
suicide en ce moment j'ai droit à trente
deux courtes minutes de pur bonheur
durant l'heure du dîner
melman dernièrement été volés jour après
jour par là-même étudiants mal habillés
et chialeuse j'en suis donc venu à la
conclusion qu'il valait mieux pour moi
de retrouver le vide éternelle il ya
deux types de personnes dans le monde
les personnes qui excelle naturellement
dans la vie et les personnes qui
espèrent les voir tous crever dans une
grande explosion tu as vu le chandail de
merde que mon frère portes dès que j'ai
eu 13 ans il est devenu clair que
j'appartenais à ce deuxième type de
personne existe-t-il vraiment mais c'est
à ça que servent les meilleurs amis nick
est là il est juste trop sexe et j'avais
christophe wister mon frère sérieux je
peux pas nier ce que je ressens tu
devenu une personne complètement
différente et c'est de voir les choses
du bon côté
je peux écrire à l'avant sa prochaine
chose que tu vas me j'ai pas le temps de
joie des petits jeux et nadine
félicitations toujours une réponse à
tout non et c'est pour ça que j'aimerais
avoir une mère qui voit que je vais pas
bien puisque j'ai fait pour mériter un
enfant si parfait rld
c'est peut-être juste une mauvaise
journée qui pensent pas possible j'ai
même plus d'amis en ce moment la vie et
pas toujours justes nadine hockey passe
à autre chose
et c'est donc normal socialise
pour vivre pleinement faut prendre des
risques n'ai jamais peur de faire preuve
d'audace ni que tu es super et tout ce
que je veux c'est être avec toi on peut
le faire dans l'arrière boutique de
l'animalerie mais je peux pas lui
envoyer sa non non non non non margot
non c'est pas si mal tout ce que je veux
c'est avec toi j'aimerais que tu matin
beauchamp on peut le faire dans
l'arrière boutique de l'animalerie
oh my god je vous en prie pitié des mois
tu dois faire attention phrases trop
lent